[Musica]
quante volte vi siete date un'occhiata
allo specchio prima di uscire per vedere
se era tutto a posto
quante volte avete detto a vostro figlio
vostra figlia o vi siete sentiti dire
non penserai mica di uscire così
l'apparenza conta conta moltissimo
diciamo che l'abito non fa il monaco
eppure le famiglie italiane benestanti
spendono in media 2.500 euro l'anno in
scarpe e vestiti l'apparenza conta
moltissimo è una base sulla quale ci
formiamo un primo sommario giudizio
sulle persone che incontriamo per questo
giudizio avrà un'importanza fondamentale
nelle interazioni successive pubblicità
in media ci ricordano soprattutto se
siamo donne quanto sia importante
correggere i propri difetti curare il
corpo ci ricordano che la bellezza e la
giovinezza sono le nostre armi
principali sono un capitale ci ricordano
quanto sia importante corrispondere agli
standard di bellezza che ci sono
prescritti ci invitano a fare un lavoro
quotidiano che comporta soldi risorse
tempo progetto sulla bellezza sul corpo
eppure ecco il paradosso quando le donne
si sono messe a pubblicare dei self i
sui social network c'è stata una levata
di scudi da parte dell'opinione pubblica
ma anche dei media che le ha chiamate
superficiali vanitose lacci esiste ma
chi possono interessare delle immagini
di questo tipo che si credono di essere
allora la bellezza deve contare ma non
deve contare troppo per le donne
chiediamo le donne di essere belle e
femminili però allo stesso tempo ci dà
fastidio quando ne vanno fieri
chiariamo le donne di lavorare
quotidianamente investire tempo soldi e
risorse sulla loro apparenza ma ci dia
fastidio quando ri ostentano i risultati
sul eurofili instagram alla fine della
campagna elettorale per le elezioni
presidenziali negli stati uniti nel 2016
hillary clinton all'indomani
dell'annuncio della sua sconfitta si è
presentata davanti alle telecamere
vestita semplicemente senza trucco con
gli occhiali i capelli non impiega dopo
questa apparizione i media l'hanno
chiamata l'hanno definita sciatta e
trasandata però durante la campagna
elettorale quando hillary clinton si
presentava perfettamente vestita per
e truccata e perfettamente pettinata
veniva criticata perché troppo fredda
troppo distante
come vedete non c'era modo di fare bene
comunque sia hillary clinton non era mai
abbastanza femminile abbastanza donna
abbastanza accurata e bella da una parte
o abbastanza accessibile e disponibile
dall altra
durante gli ultimi due anni ho condotto
una ricerca sul rapporto che le donne
hanno con la bellezza e mi sono sentita
dire dalle mie partecipanti molto spesso
una cosa che mi ha fatto pensare
ossia che la bellezza per le donne è
un'arma a doppio taglio
ha sempre e comunque delle conseguenze
negative può essere un peso per le donne
è di questo che vorrei parlarvi stasera
del fatto che noi stiamo bene almeno una
società siamo in una cultura che
attribuisce valore alle donne sulla base
della loro apparenza che anzi per dire
di più
concede legittimità credibilità alle
donne a condizione che abbiano una bella
apparenza fiabe classiche e film
contemporanei se lo ricordano
continuamente la bella fanciulla è
quella che vince sempre
è quella che può sperare in una mobilità
sociale ascendente attraverso
naturalmente un matrimonio facoltoso con
il classico principio le sue
reincarnazioni contemporanei magnate
della finanza
e lei che è degna di attenzione le donne
brutte sono sorelle invidiose sono
amiche problematiche a madri disturbate
sono indegne non hanno storia fin da
piccole impariamo quanto l'approvazione
sociale ci venga sulla base della nostra
apparenza lo diamo le bambine per i loro
opzioni per i loro vestitini i loro bei
capelli magari poi alla fine si chiede
anche loro se sono bravi a fare qualcosa
impariamo fin da piccole che la bellezza
e la giovinezza sono il nostro capitale
una volta perse quelle non avremmo forse
molto da offrire
allora mi direte è naturale che le donne
investano sulla bellezza all apparenza
perché queste portano loro un vantaggio
però ed è qui il problema la bellezza in
realtà per le donne non è solo sempre è
inequivocabilmente un vantaggio
essa è spesso è proprio perché il valore
che le donne si vedono attribuire ne
dipende
altre tre cose un peso un terreno minato
è un rischio
la bellezza è un peso perché abbellirsi
non è sempre un piacere come lo
dipingono le pubblicità è spesso un
obbligo una costrizione un'ingiunzione
siamo obbligate a un lavoro quotidiano
per renderci presentabili per
corrispondere a degli standard di
bellezza che tra l'altro cambiano
continuamente una delle partecipanti
alla mia ricerca mi ha detto che in casa
sua spesso la mattina ci sono talmente
tante cose da fare che lei non ha tempo
di vestirsi e pettinarsi come vorrebbe
prima di uscire di casa per accompagnare
i suoi tre figli a scuola però in quelle
mattine si vergogna perfino a uscire di
macchina per portarle fino all'ingresso
della scuola
oltre a questo lavoro quotidiano per
rendersi presentabile per corrispondere
agli standard di bellezza c'è anche un
lavoro a lungo termine quello per
mantenersi le pubblicità di prodotti e
servizi legati alla bellezza spesso
adottano questa retorica
dell'investimento per il futuro
la bellezza è un capitale per un
capitale che non frutta da sé su cui
bisogna lavorare continuamente
certo mi direte le donne possono
decidere di non conformarsi possono
decidere di rifiutare gli standard di
bellezza che le sono loro prescritti
però le sanzioni in cui andrea coni
andranno incontro sono importanti spesso
e volentieri le donne che non si
conformano sono considerate come
problematiche come sospette
inoltre la bellezza può essere come
dicevo un terreno minato perché è un
terreno minato perché la bellezza è in
costante e sempre incompiuta la bellezza
in costante il corpo si ribella sempre
al lavoro che facciamo per disciplinarlo
torna sempre a uno stato meno
disciplinato meno desiderabile i peli
ricrescono i capelli vanno fuori piega
il trucco va rifatto e cassiano e tutto
questo chiaramente va contro tutto il
lavoro che noi facciamo per disciplinare
il corpo
eccola l'incostanza domattina mi
sveglierò con gli occhiali e domattina
mi dovrò mettere più correttore eccetera
eccetera
oltre a questa incostanza c'è alcun
incompiutezza della della bellezza
perché non c'è un momento nella vita
della donna in cui una donna possa dire
basta ho raggiunto la bellezza non devo
fare più niente non mi devo più depilare
non devo più andare dal parrucchiere non
devo più fare ginnastica non devo più
contare le calorie
ho finito non esiste questo momento il
corpo si ribella il corpo cambia e
generalmente come voi sapete i segni
dell'invecchiamento non vanno molto
d'accordo con i canoni di bellezza che
sono prescritti alle donne
ecco qua il terreno minato perché le
donne in realtà non ci possono mai
camminare perfettamente rilassate non si
possono mai fidare completamente della
loro apparenza ma proprio perché il
valore che loro si attribuiscono il
valore che la società attribuisce loro
riposa su questa questo terreno minato e
esso essere continuamente in discussione
questo valore essere continuamente
instabile e in più questo terreno minato
e infinito perché non c'è un momento in
cui il lavoro della bellezza può finire
il lavoro dell'adeguamento ai canoni
della bellezza può finire
naturalmente questo questa logica questo
stato di cose fa il gioco del mercato
dei prodotti dei servizi legati alla
bellezza perché la migliore cliente
quella che si considera come un progetto
interminabile
in terzo luogo la bellezza è un rischio
è particolarmente il rischio per le
donne di essere ridotte alla loro
apparenza prima di tutto una donna che
ha una bella apparenza viene considerata
spesso come stupida superficiale
probabilmente un po vanitosa in secondo
luogo una bella una donna bella una
donna dalla bella apparenza viene spesso
considerata una persona incline a una
sessualità promiscua o come si dice in
termini generali una persona di facili
costumi noi viviamo che ci piaccia o no
in una società in una cultura che mette
il desiderio sessuale maschile al centro
delle dinamiche sessuali il che vuol
dire che una donna che ha un apparenza
desiderabile viene considerata
immediatamente come un oggetto legittimo
di piacere
desiderio sessuale maschile come sanno
tutte le donne che si sono fatte
abbordare per strada si sono fatte
mettere le mani addosso su un autobus
questo piacere è generalmente non
consensuale non condiviso e univoco
sapete bene come sia diventata una
consuetudine nelle aule dei tribunali
durante i processi per violenza sessuale
chiedere alle vittime di stupro come
erano vestiti al momento della violenza
come dire beh se ti vesti così te la sei
cercata
il movimento mi to che ha avuto un
impatto globale è stata una ribellione
contro questo modo di pensare con questa
logica che vuole che un apparenza
desiderabile voglia dire anche un
consenso implicito irrevocabile a
diventare oggetto di piacere sessuale
maschile in oltre l'apparenza delle
donne viene utilizzata anche nella
retorica per delegittimare la loro voce
la loro presenza la loro credibilità
l'osservatorio box diritti ha pubblicato
qualche settimana fa il quarto rapporto
sull'intolleranza sui social media e
analizzato più di 200.000 tweaks che
sono stati pubblicati su twitter dal
maggio del 2018 al maggio del 2019
di questi un quarto erano diretti contro
donne tweet di odio di insulti di
intolleranza che si dirigevano le donne
nella maggior parte di essi era la loro
apparenza e la loro sessualità a essere
al centro dell'insulto
questa situazione è stata denunciata
dalla scritte rile dalla scrittrice
michela murgia su facebook perché lei
stessa è stata per più di un anno
vittima di questi attacchi
guardate quello che succede in questi
giorni con brigitte bach o con la
neoeletta ministra dell'agricoltura in
italia
ecco perché dicevo prima che la bellezza
è un'arma a doppio taglio perché ha
sempre delle conseguenze negative per le
donne per chi la usa per chi ci lavora
la bellezza procura le donne una
visibilità e questa visibilità però le
sottopone a una sorveglianza sociale è
strettissima una sorveglianza da parte
della collettività
la bellezza procura le donne visibilità
e nello stesso tempo le espone al
rischio di essere insultati e molestate
aggredite
reggio le donne investono molte risorse
tempo soldi progettualità sulla bellezza
e sulla loro apparenza
ed è proprio questo lavoro e questo
investimento che limita la loro capacità
di azione nei contesti più diversi da
quelli personali a quelli pubblici da
quelli ricreativi a quelli professionali
eccolo il doppio vincolo della bellezza
doppio vincolo vuol dire che non si può
mai far bene qualunque scelta è una
scelta sbagliata
investire sulla bellezza può comportare
problemi non farlo può comportare
altrettanti problemi come si esce da
questo doppio vincolo come si esce da
questo dilemma alcuni voci dei
femminismi hanno attaccato violentemente
la cultura che attribuisce valore alle
donne sulla base della loro apparenza
hanno criticato il mercato dei prodotti
e dei servizi legati alla bellezza hanno
invitato le donne incoraggiato le donne
a non conformarsi e non assoggettarsi
non fatelo questo lavoro però una
strategia del genere non funziona non
funziona perché prima di tutto trasforma
una battaglia politica di nuovo in una
questione di volontà individuale
liberatevi emancipate vi da sole e
secondo perché non cambia la cultura che
attribuisce un valore una legittimità le
donne sulla base della loro apparenza
guardate che cosa è successo l'estate
scorsa ci sono state polemiche sui
giornali perché alcune donne pubbliche
fotografate in pubbliche sembravano non
portare registrano sotto i vestiti
perché questo dovrebbe interessare a
qualcuno dovrebbe essere di interesse
collettivo quando è stata l'ultima volta
in cui avete letto un articolo
ho visto un servizio alla televisione
sul fatto che a tale o tal altro uomo
politico si vedeva la linea delle
mutande con la maglietta della salute
sotto i vestiti
queste strategie non funzionano bisogna
cambiare la cultura ci vogliono delle
iniziative a largo raggio
ci vogliono iniziative politiche e
programmi educativi produzioni culturali
messaggi mediatici che vadano in
un'altra direzione
ci vuole una classe politica meno
sessista che lavori concretamente a
costruire l'eguaglianza fra gli uomini e
le donne
bisogna insegnare alle bambine fin da
piccole ad apprezzarsi per le loro mille
qualità poi da ultimo perché sono carine
bisogna insegnare ai bambini ad
apprezzare e riconoscere le loro
compagne per tutte le loro qualità
il loro senso dell'umorismo loro
simpatia la loro forza fisica e solo da
ultimo perché sono anche carine
siamo noi a dover resistere alla
tentazione di snocciolare giudizi sui
corpi delle donne in bikini sulla
spiaggia oppure di commentare su quanto
la nostra amica sei ingrassata in ultimo
anno siamo noi a dover resistere alla
tentazione di descrivere una donna prima
di tutto per le sue caratteristiche
fisiche e magari metterla il ridicolo
per s
siamo noi e fin da domani mattina a
dover togliere dalle spalle delle donne
il peso della bellezza grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]